und king charles julia soll ja auch so
ein bisschen seine finger mit im spiel
haben bei der ersten zarten annäherung
zwischen den fed vor also zwischen
william und kate und harry und magenta
soll er ja auch willi ein bisschen dazu
gedrängt haben aber auf ihn eingewirkt
haben damit diese vier sich endlich
wieder verein und das haben sie dann nur
das angesprochen auch für ganz kurzen
moment gemacht hier sehen wir die bilder
vom wochenendes waren überraschender
auftritt dieser vier und auch heute
wollen uns natürlich anschauen die sich
das weiter entwickelt schauen wir
zunächst auf diesen auftritt die vier
wieder vereint und die große frage
dahinter wird der tod der queen diese
vier zusammenbringen
dieser befehl kam von ganz oben für
einen moment waren die fantastic four
wieder vereint seite an seite in trauer
verbunden zeigten sich william und kate
jetzt prinz und prinzessin von wales mit
prinz harry und herzogin medien am
wochenende vor dem schloss windsor um
der queen ihrer großmutter zu gedenken
mehr als 40 minuten verbrachten sie mit
den menschen spendeten trost namen
blumen entgegen und ehrten die crew es
ist das erste mal seit über zwei jahren
dass die vier zusammen in der
öffentlichkeit zu sehen sind und auch
wenn der anlass tief traurig ist so
zeigen diese bilder was sich royal fans
seit jahren sehnlichst wünschen den
frieden zwischen den zwei brüdern
es ist total überraschend terry und
megan hier zu sehen es ist schön sie
alle zusammen zu sehen
ich denke es zieht einen schlussstrich
unter das was passiert ist auch aus
historischer sicht und es zeigt den
großen zusammenhalt der royalen familie
es war wunderschön dass sie heute zu
sehen waren
ich denke sie werden einfach alles unter
den teppich kehren und einfach wieder
brüder sein
doch wie kam es zu der lang erwarteten
wiedervereinigung vielleicht sogar einer
ersten versöhnung
britischen medien zufolge sollen sie
dafür verantwortlich sein prinz william
und könig charles
william soll harry und megan persönlich
eingeladen haben gemeinsam mit ihm und
kate zu trauern eine geste ein kleines
friedensangebot dass harry und merken
wohl angenommen haben doch freiwillig
soll diese einladung nicht ausgesprochen
worden sein charles william angerufen
und ein machtwort gesprochen haben er
habe verlangt dass seine zerstrittenen
söhne ihren zwist nach dem tod der
großmutter wenigstens in der
öffentlichkeit beilegen und das mit
erfolg wie diese bilder beweisen
vielleicht bringt die gemeinsame trauer
die brüder auch in zukunft wieder näher
zusammen queen elizabeth hätte sich das
jedenfalls sehr gewünscht
ich habe wie echt ist das jetzt dass die
dort so vertraut plötzlich wieder
nebeneinander laufen sie sagen es uns ja
nicht selbst in diesen stunden also
brauchen wir einen körpersprache
expertin wir brauchen thema building
dazu live hierbei bild live sie herzlich
also wenn wir die vier jetzt wird euch
wieder vereint sehen das ist doch das
bild dieses wochenendes das uns alle
überrascht hat ist das echt oder
gespielt
also ganz wichtig ist zu wissen dass
william versucht tatsächlich
brückenbauer und versöhner zu sein also
er spricht immer mal wieder auch nebenan
und er versucht auch blickkontakt zu
seinem bruder aufzubauen aber harry
zeigt ihm tatsächlich die kalte schulter
also als william zweimal versucht harry
wirklich anzuschauen würdigt harry
william keines blickes ganz stark alt
schaut er geradeaus und wir sehen
einerseits die annäherungsversuche von
william er will versöhnen ja und medien
geht auch ein stück weit darauf ein aber
harry zeigt die kalte schulter daher
sprachlosigkeit zwischen den brüdern und
kate macht es eben so also kate zeigt
keinerlei annäherung zu harry oder auch
zu sagte otsu zu anderen prinzessin zu
merken es gibt keinen einzigen blick
zwischen kate und megan das heißt kate
versucht praktisch so zu tun als ob
harry und merken überhaupt nicht da sind
als ob sie luft wären und das gleiche
macht harry seinem bruder und seiner
schwägerin gegenüber over also das sind
keine guten zeichen die wir daraus lesen
mit platzt dann wenigstens mit den
paaren untereinander also mägen und
harry da fragt man sich ja immer sind
die wirklich glücklich miteinander in
hollywood und den hühnern die sie dort
halten und aber die halten trotzdem die
ganze zeit händchen da fragt man sich
auch wie echt ist das zwischen denen
sehen sie da kleine zeichen der liebe in
der körper körpersprache ja das ist auch
eine sehr gute frage also wenn wir die
beiden paare vergleichen harry und
medien die sind wirklich sehr innig ja
sie sind sehr nah halten immer wieder
händchen märgen streicht immer wieder
über harrys rücken oder hält ihn an der
hüfte sie sind sehr sehr nah und es wird
sehr echt und sehr authentisch marge
ausgeführten merken will harry beistehen
und wir den stückweit trösten weil er so
ganz alleine isoliert sonst da ist und
auf der anderen seite das ist
interessant william und kate haben kein
einziges mal körperkontakt kein händchen
halten keine berührung gar nichts das
ist auch eine große distanz zwischen
diesen pass könnte man sagen gut die
sind halt sehr konservativ die sind halt
sehr steif ja während medien und harrier
diese cooleren lockeren sind aber es
schon interessant einerseits kein
körperkontakt zwischen william und kate
und dann diese ähnlichkeit dieser
authentische nähe und verbundenheit
zwischen harry und megan ist das
ähnlichkeit oder ist das unsicherheit
weil man sich die ganze zeit an der hand
hält dort
also es wirkt nicht so als ob sie sich
so aneinander klammern an dem strohhalm
weil da gerade niemand anders da ist
sondern es wirkt wirklich so dass da
verbundenheit da ist dass da auch
wirklich liebe da ist und es ist ein
besonders großer kontrast zum andern
paar und es ist vor allem ein großer
kontrast zu der eiseskälte die zwischen
kate auf der einen seite und harry und
megan herrscht und auch zwischen harry
und william also vor allem von harry
ausgehend diese kalte schulter die er
zeigt kein blickkontakt diese
sprachlosigkeit einmal das auch sehr
interessant ist es genau diese szene die
wir hier sehen da ist es nämlich so dass
harry eigentlich sein bruder hätte
angucken müssen als er aus diesem tor
kommt das wäre auf natürliche art und
weise so gewesen aber demonstrativ guckt
er zur seite um ja nie seinen bruder
auch wirklich anschauen zu müssen und
blickkontakt ist nun mal wie es wichtig
in der körpersprache her geht es um
vertrauen und da geht es auch um
zuneigung und wenn jemand keinen
blickkontakt hat heißt es kälte
verachtung ein ganz tiefer graben
zwischen den brüdern und auch zwischen
den paaren war also wir schauen heute
nochmal in den gedenkgottesdienst und
schauen mal ganz genau darauf wie sich
die vier dann verhalten letzte frage
noch zu merken ich finde ja auch sie hat
harry da ganz gut bei gestand man sagen
dann auch den kleinen harry also als er
vor den blumenstand die damals für seine
mutter diana ausgelegt waren deswegen
glaube ich auch noch ein ganz
schwieriger schritt wieder vor so einem
blumenmeer zu stehen kommt mit
sicherheit so bilder aus der
vergangenheit hat man sich wohl gefühlt
hat merkel sich sicher gefühlt es gibt
ja zwei lager die einen sagen das ist
eine böse berechnende schlange und die
anderen sagen endlich tut sie mal was
dafür dass 87 modernisiert was lesen sie
raus aus ihrer körpersprache hat sie
sich da wohl gefühlt in dieser rolle
hier also der sich am wohlsten gefühlt
es war harry aber morgen schien wirklich
bei sich zu sein und william der ja
versucht hat versöhner und brückenbauer
zu sein und zu seinem bruder hat
überhaupt nicht geklappt aber zu melden
hat es geklappt also bildung ist immer
wieder auf dem berg in kurz eingegangen
merken auch signalisiert dass sie
praktisch da auch entsprechend positiv
darauf reagiert und melden war wirklich
bei sich und hat vor allem ihrem mann
ist sie bei gestanden hat sie
unterstützt vor allem emotional hat sie
ihn stark unterstützt und das war sehr
glaubwürdig und es war auch überraschen
dass sie so selbstbewusst aber so bei
sich auch so stimmig für sich auch
aufgetreten ist faszinierend was sie
alles raus lesen dort aus der
körpersprache der vier nächste chance
nun gleich in kürze nämlich der
trauergottesdienst dann in edinburgh wo
alle wieder vor ort sein werden und auch
dann sind wir auf jede bewegung dort
gespannt danke ihnen vielen dank in st
[Musik]